the inside of an engine may not be as
sexy as some of the car pictures you've
seen in your dad's car magazines that's
driving driving right here all right
there's one thing I want you guys to
take away from drivers Adam it's don't
drive if you have to drive we're a sheep
though
but don't drive so how is driver's ed
going at school it's fine too many
questions sir you really don't want to
talk about this okay and don't forget
when you drive with somebody it's like
driving with everyone Dave ever driven
with drop with some guy you're driving
with all the girls
you drove with I want you to know buddy
be selective yeah we need one car really
so you've only ever driven one car Kenny
we're talking about you now not me yes
can two boys drive together hmm nope you
had no idea that that's what it looked
like on the inside should we be looking
at this OOP it's growth you get yourself
into a wreck we have a busted fender the
rest your life no one's gonna want to
drive with you you know God wants you to
wait to drive I don't know how that can
be true Jesus never drove so I don't
know why you need to what do you do if
your carburetor breaks down you don't
need to know that I don't want to wait
to drive because I don't want to get to
college and find out I'm a bad driver no
I wish my dad had talked to me about
this but he didn't I uh I had to learn
this in the streets on my own Oh talk
about a misspent youth can't I just like
drive for fun cuz I hear it's really fun
no driving is only to get you where you
need to go there are plenty of good
alternatives to driving like walking
Vikings fun I've got one was laid in
know I wanted mr. Stevens to come in
here today and talk to the girls but she
wasn't available so I'm gonna have to do
it
hey k yeah
yeah like one minute Allison what is
this they gave it to us in driver's ed
this is just encouraging you to drive
everybody take one pamphlet take them
home read them everything okay buddy
yeah I uh yeah I didn't see anything why
is the gym teacher teaching us how to
drive I don't know but he hasn't driven
in years wanna drive fast but sometimes
slow to enjoy the few yesterday you were
playing with those little Hot Wheels and
now you're getting the real friend dad
this one seems like a scented